[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Democrat Phil Murphy
replaced Chris Christie today as
governor of New Jersey and one of the
very first things he did was create a
new high profile state agency can you
guess what it's gonna do it won't be
stamping out rampant opioid abuse in New
Jersey unfortunately it won't be working
to boost that state's lagging economy
either it won't fix the budget which is
perpetually in deficit or even fill some
those ubiquitous potholes that test your
shock absorbers when you pull off for
coffee on the Garden State Parkway it
certainly won't be fighting crime in
fact it will be doing just the opposite
Governor Phil Murphy's new state task
force will exist explicitly to subvert
and undermine America's existing laws
the office is called the office of
immigrant defense protection it'll often
offer legal assistance to illegal
immigrants so they can evade deportation
or at least delay it long enough to
receive the driver's licenses and
taxpayer-funded College aid that
governor Murphy also wants to give them
so the message of all this could not be
clearer governor Murphy's top priority
is not the citizens of New Jersey but
instead people who shouldn't be there in
the first place if you don't believe
that take a look at New Jersey cities
nearly all of which are hurting badly
and have been for generations
Camden right across the river from
Philadelphia is one of the toughest
places on this continent its
unemployment rate is more than double
the national average 30 percent of its
residents live below the poverty line
parts of it are so dangerous you
wouldn't walk down the street Newark and
Patterson are not much better than that
but governor Murphy has not announced a
new state agency to fix those places no
other liberal governor in America is
doing that either because let's be
honest
Democrats have given up on blighted
American neighborhoods the schools are
terrible they're not getting better the
people there shoot each other who knows
why unemployment broken families drug
addiction it is a tragedy in slow motion
and everybody knows it but where is the
energy to make any of it better to help
our fellow Americans
well it's been siphoned off to serve a
new and more fashionable cause one not
incidentally with greater long-term
electoral prospects illegal immigrants
that's the new cause as for the American
poor people whose families have been
here for 300 years and are still
suffering and dying young as long as
Democrats take their votes for granted
they'll continue to get lip service and
that's it John McCain has remember the
New Jersey Assemblyman he joins us
tonight mister we can't thanks for come
on thanks for having me on Tucker so I
just checked the numbers and in Newark
New Jersey I think the states still the
biggest city about 12% of high schoolers
are adequate in math in Camden among
kids in grades 3 through 8 at 7% have
reached the math standard why wouldn't
the incoming governor make that as
priority and not legal aid to illegal
aliens well I think you're unfair and
the premise of what you said and first
and foremost as it relates to New Jersey
5 there's 500,000 on document it's in
our state that's 6 percent of our
population so they're not the criminals
that you port purport them to be they're
our neighbors and our friends come in
all's well I'm not calling them is what
I'm calling them is not Americans which
they are and my and I'm not against them
actually I think they're probably mostly
nice people but I think the government
has a duty first and foremost to protect
its own people and in New Jersey as you
know I used to live in the state so I
know to has cities that are crumbling
and pathetic and dangerous and the
schools are terrible so where where's
the emphasis on that well I don't know
where you're saying the schools are
terrible and first off governor Murphy
is going to make schools and fully
funding a priority we have some of the
best public schools in the nation so you
can you know pick and choose different
scores from cities that have their own
issues and try again to make an
inappropriate this is Newark the biggest
city in New Jersey I think it was where
D City of Newark give or take about the
same so if you've got 12% of high
schoolers adequate in math do you think
that's a success of course it isn't then
we can always do better and that's one
of the governor's priorities but I
thought we came to talk about the
department that is going to look after
yeah those who are refugee because it's
a state and Emin start holding that we
have to make sure they have access to
adequate information no different than
adequate legal services so I think we'll
both agree that a government's first job
is to take care of its own sister
it's the ones who put it in power in the
first place whose votes give it
legitimacy so how does giving financial
aid for college tuition to illegals help
American citizens in New Jersey you know
you're skipping ahead to all of that
when it comes to it what we need to do
you know when you look at what's
happened now within the last
year-and-a-half or year of President
Trump we've seen statistics go down from
from a crime reporting perspective among
the Latino population as it relates to
domestic violence as it relates to
sexual assault down by as much as 20
percent why is that it's because they're
afraid to report it is that in our best
interest to keep us safe do you think
that criminals are discriminating and
just going after undocumented I think we
may have been conversations we may be
having parallel conversations I just
asked you the governor I think today
said our plan is to use taxpayer money
to help the children of people here
illegally go to college and my and I
know why it's great for them I can see
where they're happy about it why should
a New Jersey resident who's an American
citizen think this helps him well over
all that you're taking a piece of the
component of what we're gonna be talking
about we're talking about driver's
licenses now guess what I'm document
it's Drive anyway isn't it better to
make sure that they take a safety test
or better prepared to do so can get
drivers to get insurances and that in
all of our best interest to make
probably best if they left but since
they're here look I get it you're not
gonna answer my question about college
tuition how about this Democrats tell us
that there are millions of African
Americans Americans citizens who don't
have driver's licenses why is a new
jersey starting a program to get them
driver's licenses instead giving them to
illegal aliens with a new program I'm
missing it why I didn't know that the
show or your bent was to force people to
do things that they can otherwise do you
wouldn't suggest that we should force
licenses on people right that's not I
don't think your philosophy suggesting
that I'm just saying Democrats always
saying we can't have voter ID laws
because a lot of african-americans don't
have IDs here your state is saying we're
gonna help people here illegally get IDs
wanted help your own people first that's
the theme I'm asking about I'm not
getting a real answer yeah I don't even
get into the voter ID fee piece because
as you know that's only about voter
suppression and you're picking on groups
of people that happen to vote Democratic
that you're trying to keep from asking
but you're not
instead of helping illegal aliens and
but let's get to my my question my
college aid every parent in America
worries about the cost
now taxpayers in New Jersey was
subsidizing the cost for illegal aliens
why does that help them why does that
help citizens of New Jersey didn't you
say she said you should throw them all
out I mean could you really be
suggesting that we're gonna take a half
a million people in our state and deport
them could you be suggesting that we're
not going to so you don't have a
nationwide you don't send them out of
this country I don't know about this let
me that's a different thing maybe you
should start with explaining to our
viewers why it's in their interest as
American citizens to see their tax
dollars go to educate people here
illegally how does it help that that's a
fair question we think it's a fair
question and eventually you win their
sanity in Washington when there's a path
to citizenship for the 11 million people
that are here and undocumented because
they'll never be all removed you know
that then those allowing individuals to
become educated will make them more
productive citizens and an important
part of our fiber in this country you're
suggesting to our advantage
why isn't ever anybody's advantage to
you know provide aid to people it's to
make them more productive and better
citizens in our country but there are
lots of Americans a lot of Americans
most Americans who worry about the cost
of tuition for their kids it's their
country why not take that money and give
it to them to help their kids I don't
understand a whole different topic is
you know governor Murphy and one of his
priorities is relating to having junior
colleges and tuition free for New Jersey
citizens that are good students so there
is much by way of programs that you're
just focusing on the one having to do
with supporting those who are
undocumented and particularly the
dreamers the refugees as well as green
card holders to have a Clearing House
legal aid so they can understand what
their options are and not be afraid
that's a fight and fight federal law
yeah I get it
okay thanks a lot of Selman I appreciate
it thank you for having